if I did a trade under the
or I would then on the
representative to say the group
run the department store so um but
Rudolf Karstadt by the way um um his
Essen group but the first store in
Wismar in Mecklenburg-Western Pomerania was the
first Karstadt department store that he Georg
Wertheim, the first Wertheim was in
Stralsund, 30 km from my hometown,
they didn’t make it for me,
this deal, that’s why
you two, one person helps, your list,
that’s actually possible, so Dieter
schwarz, you have to have it there,
boys, are you ready?  let's go um
maybe Flo um just say
two short sentences to yourself because you're
new here a round and then once something
have learned yes exactly normally
you don't hear my voice but he
loves me maybe then you he loves
me at least  in the background I
take care of the ears of the podcast in the editorial department
at OMR,
i.e. the preparation follow-up
everything around it without
you have to say very clearly yes thank you very much
and the possibility there you can see
your face from time to time my winking
face and  Of course, as
always when we don't know much further, we tapped into our
digital is big brain or economy
is big brain from, uh,
East Western Pomerania and invited us
again from the Doppelganger podcast,
known from various other podcasts
and here also a regular guest, so
I'm happy to complete the round
be very much involved and definitely learn
a lot but very generally be
on the idea of ​​not
having a finished list now it is anyway
you can’t absolutely set but
what to learn I think you have that
regularly why do you do podcasts
if you  I can learn something myself
and I'm just now learning a bit about
history but I've noticed
crass things myself I don't even know and I
hope that many hear it too
that you think the next few minutes
oh crass interesting has made Bock
so let's start  Let's start with the first one,
also thanks to the support of
LinkedIn, our listeners have my
list of well over 100 names and there was
actually everything from A for
Albrecht to Z for Zuse, the
inventor of the computer
and yes, we had many
family businesses  had many
trading companies, many
women entrepreneurs actually some
founders who
have only become successful in recent years
and have tried to narrow it down a bit and put
some on a short list and it is really
interesting which names are not on it in the end
that yes, you could
probably have put together a list completely
differently and would
also have mentioned a lot of names,
yes they are, but somehow
you have to limit yourself
and one question that really occupied us in the
preparation
was e.g. how do you go about it  there are an
awful lot of big
names on this lonelist, an awful lot of successful
entrepreneurs who, of course, also
have a somewhat dark history during
the National Socialist era, of course,
where we of course first
asked ourselves how do we deal with it,
well,
from people where we  then
actually thought madness story but
you can't so unrestrictedly here
tendrils yes for example Robert Bosch
so Bosch is still known today as a
huge company Adolf dasler the
founder of Adidas
Herbert quant who saved BMW and
made it big Albert Reimann from recid
bankiser  who invented Calgon
are really
really active as Nazis in some way or just
somehow forced into a Wehrmacht
or can you
pause like that
in the end there is from to ne I would
say but of course there were
ardent advocates there were
manufacturers  who have now made their factories
available
to produce weapons there were
manufacturers or entrepreneurs who employed
forced laborers in their factories,
so there was almost everything there and
there were also extreme cases like now, for
example, Reinhard Mohn, who
actually after the  War first
came a prisoner of war in the
USA, where it was also purified a bit
and in the end, so to speak,
this image of
individualism of freedom also
came to Germany and
then continued in a completely different way than it
might have done during the
National Socialist
era  why on my top ten list at the
same time maybe then maybe
here of course the not good animals
part of his past but also for
an addition we also considered
including a person on the list
who then became famous
through a film also German
entrepreneurs but if you then  Well,
Mr. Schindler's company
was quite small, but of course
an amazing act saved a lot of people's
lives in World War II
or something like that at that time, insofar as
you could have said that,
of course, one could have been enough for a
nomination, but
we want to  yes then look at the
economic things and do
n't evaluate the other things because it's
just so difficult actually
and sometimes we also had the problem on the long
list that we
had company names or names of people who
had done an incredible amount economically but  where
at the end of satire it was released
is it now an entrepreneur or is
it more of a manager, for example
Uli Hoene's Bayern manager now
honorary president has of course
set up a sausage factory at the same time, so it
has also become entrepreneurially active
and you can of course also say in
its role  as a manager he
made an incredible amount out of Bavaria but is
now full-time and then always
was or was it rather an
employee of the club no and
that is one that you know yes I have
a place here on my list that
I wanted  listen to your pitches right away
but one of these
vacancies if you don't convince me with
your ideas for your top ten list then
I would be appointed by Höhn is among
other things because I think
he owns the company if he doesn't
he was the  driving force he turned an
irrelevant club into a German
global brand that would probably
be worth four five billion if it were a company or
if you could act like
Chelsea is now like others
that's still small on the list
because we'll take most of the others  will
soon have
built even more valuable companies,
but I think it's halfway there today,
it has a crazy signal effect, it's
in the top league worldwide, so in
this case football and that has
just accompanied me very much
[music] all my life
insofar I have it
on a similar list let it be and
maybe we'll just go
right into the lists and from
all the application is also interesting
you just mentioned you
have to think about the
entrepreneurial performance and what should
n't it be based on  only by the wealth that you have
built up or is it measured by
the importance you had in a segment,
so maybe a market is
relatively small, but if you like 100%
owning, you have
achieved a lot as an entrepreneur, whereas the
trade, i.e. the food trade and
something else, does  Of course it's a huge market
where you can reach
extremely high
valuations in the billions or even
billions of assets with comparatively small market shares. That
was of course also a point that played
a role in our discussions,
so how big is
the market in which you are in the end
was an entrepreneur
yes at pipp maybe tell me when at the
beginning who did you
put where on your list so I would
briefly explain what thoughts no
longer what makes a company entrepreneur for me
is on the one hand a
risk that would be such a
speak a bit against the manager hypothesis and here it's
probably not too daring now, no, because
innovative, I think it hired great
people, but
I don't think the risk was great or the invention
of which of course also had to do
a bit of what
came out of it, either in the  In the sense of
wealth or maybe also brands that were
built up that were known around the world, that's
a bit too,
of course, also a bit of
integrity, no, that's
what he might speak against Uli,
so I think it's just the whole civic duty
always pay taxes and
those are the things that I
paid a little attention to
and I was relatively
sure that catch 1 of them from below
that maybe can do that from below
because one of our listeners had yes
or had yes on LinkedIn
another idea how to fathom this list
but they have to give props erm
exactly
or are entrepreneurs too and
this time compare the top ten list
if we have the similar rating
so he had Werner
von Siemens the founder of Siemens in first place
Second place was Robert Bosch, whom we had
just addressed with the Nazi past,
Karl Friedrich Bands
Adolf, the country of poppies, we also had
Theo and Karl Albrecht, the reasons for
Alter Schwarz, the Lidl founder, Hasso
Plattner, and Dietmar Hopp, the SAP
founders, and Frank in 10th place  Thelen
so
congruent list with with smears
so it looks very similar at the top for
me it's a little bit
off at the bottom but you can see the
shortcomings that you still have
but I so what of course shows is
that what learns from that is the
written word media  uh ultimately
and uh well Franktina has
certainly achieved so much, but above all he
is a media professional, so to speak,
and has a large media presence and
he can let you believe that, if he
is an entrepreneur, I would say he
took risks and was always there
successful sometimes unsuccessful
but that affects the entrepreneurs
but I mean I think respect for
Frank and you
said that a bit very moderately
[music]
and Dassler and those are now
really big corporations with
10,000 for me  more employees because
I don't really see him right now,
but
the one with the most LinkedIn is definitely
lost on the
list
also
present right here so there's also an
overlap so the
topic is now poorly understood
you can also argue about it but
a bit but okay that's
um who wants to do the
first ones from the bottom up I'd say
perfect with his  Place on
yes I would be very short as
remarks if you Nazi topic I
think it's just that hardly any
German company that
has existed over the time has no topic
what you
can maybe turn off a bit is how it
was dealt with later and  That's actually the case
when you look at the company chronicles, it
often says nothing, so Miele
supposedly only built bicycles and
field kitchens, but that they also
built torpedo drives,
it says that is then left out and supposedly
every company has the
forced laborers particularly well
this is also dealt with more by historikaden,
but it is noticeable
that the companies, the um, the
families behind it,
deal with it very differently and I
think you can also measure it a
bit from that, where you say
someone finds their own relationship to
truth  Or does it work really
well
with someone
who is perhaps not so well known
and, above all, no longer
lives in Germany, which is why
Andreas von Bechtolsheim or
Bechtolsheim, who founded San Micro Systems at the time, is more likely to be in the back
together with
Nord kossner, among other things, who is now a
large toilet
and it was one of the first
software companies Sun stood for
Stanford University Network I think
then built computers later
was also one of the first investors from
Google invested 100,000 US dollars
from them  500 million had already become by the time of the IPO,
so today
it will probably be several billion
if he had kept it and
is now active again as an entrepreneur
has taken the CEO post from Arista
Networks, which makes switches
for data centers, so it’s also a
boom industry every time, um  Facebook
or Google build large data centers,
either ciscounta or Arista
technology is in there and there is now
again a part of his and co
and is probably one of the
best-known German entrepreneurs in the USA with
Peter Thiel, who is German,
at least I would think so or you
have  in both I always ask that now
on the ball in 10th place so yes
I actually have
his fortune is
somehow put at around 8 billion dollars according to Forbes
he estimates but that
wasn't really that important for me
why I still put 10th place
but erm I
tried to
look a little at my list so what
levers did they actually use so what did
their entrepreneurial actions have in the
end achieved so they really
managed to change the epoch they
somehow managed to use new technology again
In case of doubt, I found
the value that you
built up as a fortune, so to speak, more relevant than that
and then I found, like you just
said, this role with
Sunrise Systems was really
one of the companies of the time
and then  also with this investment
in Google and yes also in Germany
with StarOffice supports
this Microsoft competitor,
I thought that was enough for me for
10th place actually okay well then
we have two
tenth places here now but we’ll do it  first
continue with tips ninth place
is for me else Kröner so the first
female mention that is the founder
of Fresenius who took over a pharmacy at the time
and from that
you would say it
has developed a medical technology group over a long time so hairdressing it is
today I think  Market leader for dialysis
machines, such a blood washing machine,
where diabetics
usually have to sit in earlier, later,
regularly, um, produces food solutions
for people who are artificially fed,
among other things, or various
medical solutions
over a
certain period of time in the body,
one of the two big ones in
these markets is always either the market leader or the
follower, and yes, in a short time,
I think that’s also important in the
definition of an entrepreneur, if someone now has
generations and many inheritances
with me  Grade 4-5 billion
scraped together is one thing,
but I think in life that's
relatively rare in Germany that
someone is still a real entrepreneur in his lifetime
and because this
crowner so there's a short spoiler you
've got them uh Flo in place  7 I put
her in 6th place, I think she started as a
chambermaid for the Fresenius family
and because they didn't
have any children, they
inherited them, so to speak, and then she
took over this company and then
really set the start for a
global corporation  is today is what
I think about them are two corporations
between Fresen is and Fresenes Metal
care um guess together maybe
40 50 billion because um anyway I
think that's really important
and that's why I
took them down because that's the way it is anyway  There are
few women erm
this person is completely under reports from my point of view
that's exactly that's
why I'm making this list because
people just have to hear about
such create and if I now
I don't know if I'll
post Lea Kramer or Verena now
I would now found an event and
not call it female in any way,
I should say that's that else founder with it
because that's a representative for what
you wish for and which
is kind of uhm just crazy that there was
a woman at that time, so mean  that
was the other time born 25 ne
can have exactly such a career
so there would have to be
a special episode for Fast and Furious by Verena and who, um,
or because I was then you
really have to emphasize that as a woman  that was
already blatantly unknown to me
and I once had what
shares even his first shares I
had at the time but didn’t know that it
was a female founder is now
together the companies are around 30
billion will think twelve at once
15 billion  Yes, I
actually find it interesting, too,
so I at least tried to
take it to heart a little when
considering the ones on
my list
that are actually independent, so
what the companies are worth today was not important to me,
so it
really counts for me  how much value and
that is actually very difficult to
research or practically often
not possible so how much value was
actually created in the entrepreneurial
phase of those who we
award is of course much easier
to say okay siemens is now,
for example, a huge name or
Bayer or  anything else Dax companies
but in truth the majority of the
values ​​​​that are displayed on the stock exchange today, so to speak, were
then
generated by employee managers, so to speak, ne and um, there are few
who are actually like
families now and then often their whole
Life just like that created such values,
no, and yes, by the way, another
very exciting observation regarding the DAX,
that most of the corporations, as well as
the BFF Siemens and so on,
come from the imperial era if you look at S&P
in the USA, there is this
narrative  that somehow 50 percent
of the company falls out every 20 years
because so much innovation and
venture capital influences the market
Germany is just so
that somehow I think 18 out of 20 or
at least the majority you can
say of the Dax companies really from
imperial times  so maybe they are like that
then we have at ten at pipp the
change to a
new one the Else Kröner at 8 it will be
rather strange at 8 o'clock at eight namely Graf
Zeppelin
who has the airships I think
only a few million with  after
inflation if it probably
also um billions but
known of course won by the
airship construction which then
pioneered passenger aviation later then
also used for military purposes
in the First World War
but what is very exciting about his
legacy is that the um the
Zeppelin air
shipbuilding  GmbH also
built the zahnradfabrik Friedrichshafen,
which in turn
became ZF Friedrichshafen, which
the Zeppelin Foundation
now has and I believe with a
turnover of 40 billion is one of the
largest automotive suppliers, so I would say
his legacy lived on and I would
say entrepreneurs  because he
took huge risks in the broadest sense
are also an inventor
in a brand, I would definitely
say and live in the ZF gearbox
or
you have to say I didn't
see that, I think it's a great choice, so
you're okay in 7th place  the foundation
finances half the city of
Friedrichshafen, I would assume
the entire university and so on,
everything about the Zeppelin Foundation
was okay, and in 7th place you have
someone I know here personally,
yes,
I'll go through them all once or
okay, um, there  I have Reinhold is
a bit actually a very
impressive person
the body of course also a
bit of that German cream hafter
that just
slowly and slowly built up companies over a very long time
but of course it has grown huge
I think around ten billion
when I look at it  not mistaken but also because there is
great respect for the fact that he
managed to do this during his lifetime and has also
held on to it for a very long time, you have to say, but
I think and I think
probably is the world market leader when it comes to
screws or those that you really 100%
really 100% have no stock market or no
investors  it's just his company
alone that
's already it's
competitive in terms of performance from a sporting point of view it's very difficult to
get at it and also many new perspectives
on marketing uh too uh uh too charity
and stuff like that you can listen to everything again in the podcast
if that interests you, but
I find it an impressive and, in a
way, also innovative
personality, so I
kind of thought about it and
I'm also enthusiastic, that's why I was
there too, but of course the
innovation isn't in the product, it
's a distribution  if you
want to find the money I think the secret of success will be from Mr. then
you will find it more in the sale of the
distribution and less now in what
ultimately became everything but
I would have been even more impressed
if it were somehow a product
or how do I get back to SAP right away
or something like that, that's also a sales performance
but to be
honest, that's where I say SAP, I'm
noticing myself right now that I'm
not at all sure that a greater
sales performance is also um but well,
but that was actually that  Reason
why Reinhold didn't make it onto my
top ten list
I also find it totally exciting what he
has managed to create in the course of
his career and there are also
a few ne so these these
tool
craft entrepreneurs, so to speak, so we
do  On the long list there is also the
inventor of the fischer dowel, who really
somehow became known worldwide
with this dowel on this
Fischertechnik construction kit. Also a
crazy story at the end of a
family business, but yes,
actually, I would even say
that the innovation was even greater
than it would have been  but the success
is still gigantic and
of course the period of time in his
lifetime somehow now uh yes yes we are
really discussing billionaires at the highest
billionaires billions in
sales that these companies
have made but somehow you
still have to put together a top tener like that
in the dear  For example,
they put the slewing crane in the
mobile, mountable crane, which
was also a huge breakthrough and,
together with Putter, I think a
French company, are now also
world market leaders and there are now more
Chinese products, but they are also
okay, relatively well known, okay, he has it
didn'tmake it
instead
I would call deputy so I've
got Friedrich Bayer on it that's
logically the founder of
Bayer AG umm who, like almost the entire
German chemical industry,
started with aniline so
color production from coal tar so
when you look at it you look at it  Herr von
Kohl is created and from which you
can build indigo colors that was the
beginning of
won by the way also
[music]
cholesterol more or less made first
so
acetylsalicylic acid made to the brand name
aspirin but say the
brand name is probably there what is
so well known too  Heroin is actually the
first to be criticized and
the first broadband antibiotic
kontosil built then of course whole
cities built Wuppertal Elberfeld
Leverkusen I believe emerged from
a factory that belongs to a leverkus
and that was only later
called Leverkusen because otherwise it was the
mocking name of the population for  the
place actually because it belonged to Mr.
leverkus, who had heard a small lecture
or something, one
later renamed his Leverkusen, so mine drives
much more fun
[music].
yes, even from near
Wuppertal and my father was with Bavaria for a long time,
but yes, they were actually
written with an E, but there was
some kind of scoundrel in the
city at the time who probably had scammers
and he was somehow afraid of
his reputation or something  about that of his
company and has therefore
renamed himself Bavaria with ah as it is
still known today okay actually
representative because actually
one would have to name Friedrich Engelhorn who
founded BASF that you
Baden aniline and soda factory so
there again one  Lines
started similarly Indigo Farben and Germany
was at that time virtually the chemical manufacturer in the
world. In the USA there was DuPont as a
major competitor, so to speak. Then
the German chemical industry then
joined forces with Bavarian Aqua and BASF
to form IG Farben, which of course then
had a very problematic history because  manufactured this Zyklon B
that's on the left
combat agent that was used in the concentration camps
and Bayer
also used mustard gas in the First World War and manufactured something like that,
so it's all a very
complicated story, but I think I can
say why German chemistry
needs people, that in turn was
actually true  Rather BASF but that was mentioned in
the podcast with Lukas godowski but
also
Christian Vollmann say that
Bosch processes have the
ammonia synthesis that is what
actually feeds the world to this day
and I think
the predecessor to the Justus is important again  von
Liebig is actually the one who recognized
that plants absorb nitrogen compounds
and
can thus promote growth, i.e. he
actually laid the scientific
basis and did and Bosch
then did the synthesis of ammonia for BASF,
i.e. the joining
of pieces of nitrogen from the air and
hydrogen
the entire production of fertilizers and uh
explosives was invented and
that's why a huge
economic factor for Germany was
always completely dismantled after the world wars
so you lost
most of the industrial structure again
but are definitely still interesting to
this day the important name BFF is Bavaria
I have lists like that  found
of great connection so once
this half Bosch procedure of course
but also the periodic table of the
elements for example was also
invented in Germany and of
course we also have a few inventions
then at the end where people say they
were invented by us or that was  so
the impulse that came from us but
nothing was made of it
then you can example from the
more recent time is somehow the
MP3 format ne which
was developed at the Fraunhofer Institute and yes in the end
then so to speak only now made all these
music services possible  but
also has e.g. I wasn’t aware of that
either, the lightbulb became so you think but Thomas Edison
was actually already in 1854 uh
Heinrich Göbel and never heard the
name but he had invented it,
just didn’t register the patent and that
’s 25  Years later simply
done or the telephone or also
the first invention in Germany and
not by Mr. Bell whom you otherwise
somehow know
that's kind of three examples that
we noticed during the research to be
honest on the oh crass so MP3
I knew  the other two
I actually didn't know how blatantly
well Germany was positioned like that, let
's say around 1900, what was
between 1880 and 1900 somehow 20 or something like that,
that the imperial period, everything that
happened here, there, there,
Germany was what we are today
probably see in the USA no,
you just have to clearly see
the semiconductors or, by the way,
from the principle of the chalet and brown that
would be that you should have taken with you from the chemical industry
who
basically invented the semiconductor diode
and Justus von Liebe, for example, that
with the nitrogen compounds
has also practically
invented the magic, namely such a
meat and malt extract which was then
mainly
used for field rations, of course, but
he has more or less noticed how to extract the
nutrients from plants and meat
and thus the
precursor of  Maggi from exactly that was
uh
also together with AG uh from you have but
on behalf of all those just mentioned
you now have Friedrich Bayer in sixth place
but I think that’s where I think
the big brands have created so
with, among other things,
I would say aspirate but  one could say exactly
BASF because they did the ammonia synthesis but
yes that just harbound so fritz
Haber and Karl Bosch is on
behalf of the the
Bosch you place uh exactly good
transition
exactly Robert Bosch I think I found the
magneto igniter I think
car engines for it  is today one of the
largest automotive suppliers
keeps the whole region around Stuttgart
together with the car industry
alive with
a lot of anthropic now also
on the road I think such a
foundation family foundation
[music]
incredible name that
stands for German inventiveness and Robert
Bosch is nowadays too  still
high-tech, so with
self-driving cars technology is
relatively high up you never think
of it you think of Google waymo beidu
and Tesla but Robert Bosch
actually has relatively competitive
products there
and believe how big they are because they
are just not listed on the stock exchange exactly
when  who will be on the stock exchange
some of the top DAX companies but yes one of the
world’s largest suppliers in the meantime
exactly did you
find anything else Robert Bosch what
so
I actually
thought back and forth is also
an amazing achievement of course in the end
but I had  then there are others that I
found a bit stronger in their segments,
if then we'll continue so
with you now in fourth place
you at least have Flo with you too
or tell me who is it
a married couple I think that's exactly who
You should actually already be a married couple do
n't you know the ankerkraut
founderici and Usain from biontech
so probably the youngest and
best example of how you can create
a huge fortune from science on the one hand,
but also
social impact that
is certainly still controversial, um, but I
think quickly  to 100 billion
companies I'm sure by now
I still have 30 billion or around 30
billion show that
top-level research is still being carried out in Germany in
certain segments of a
good example of that
created by immigrants, so to speak,
and a company which in the USA is even
more so than an imprint that  I know what is
also exciting, I
gave a lecture like this at HHL in Leipzig and I have
a problem, what I really see in
Germany is that there is
actually too much business administration, i.e.
economists, for reasons when
you look at the 100 billion companies
attacking the USA  so
Bill Gates was
computer science steve Jobs did a
bit of
humanities the design
philosophy but then the two
Google founders quite obviously Mark
Zuckerberg Facebook quite clearly uh self
banner anno from LVMH billion group
at the moment is not an applicant is
actually also an engineer so you  you have
these spammy professions that I believe build
the largest companies in the world
for this is also a great
example that was not founded by any business
administration but what is really
disruptive is that there were more procedures
for vaccine and
cancer therapy
and it is actually in Germany too
I don't know, but
maybe the transition to the
next place in
Germany is not that different, so
biontech is made up of people who support me, so in
that case I would assume biologists,
I don't even know what their profession
is, in any case  but a
scientific tribe or
scientific profession
but my next place would be SAP and there
are four of the five reasons
are always known Dietmar Hopp and hate
Plattner of course there is also Hektor
Shira and
shows it forgotten people Berger
uh green second I
might have that  I even wrote down
the animals Hector Plattner
Hopp exactly from which one also four out of
five computer scientists ultimately and
SAP is the only say 100
billion day company in
Germany and I think that would be
really good if we had more people
from science again  who found
and we not only so high
respectful people who have built up big
marketplaces or e-commerce for
business but the
really big influential
companies I think are made by
scientists or mixed but that's
exactly what I wanted to say because
there is, for example, this here now
Example Miele where the
karl-mühle also been in our country was
more concerned with the technical
area so
of course then ne the first
washing machine the first dishwasher the
first invented the dishes the first
dishwasher and
then at the same time the um
rain can educate the  In
public, of course, everything is
called the company again, maybe
not at all, that's more of a knowledge of this
whole area and that's ultimately
a good example of such a
team that I just
add to it and I think that's it  what
you saw recently, such a
statistic or a graphic,
someone shared with a professor from
RWTH Aachen University who takes care of
this whole topic of intro binaryship
and who also showed a bit
how many
rounds of financing and how high they were
Financing rounds with RWTH
participation are actually quite good to
see that
this yes this entrepreneurship is now obviously arriving
more at such technical universities again,
no, well, in Munich you can also see it,
uhm
yes, that more and more companies
are founded out of the natural sciences
maybe even in combination
with someone maybe from or so
you also need a good example of a
combination is Emil von Behringen,
who invented vaccines and serum
therapies together with paul Ehrlich
and built the beering works in
Marburg, where he is also practically an
entrepreneur
tried at his own risk to develop vaccines for differin and
perpetrators from and so on
or he basically got a sidekick in business administration
to manage it because he
simply didn't
call for what Christian Vollmann who was
already mentioned as a guest
here  said you
actually need mixed teams, so
actually if someone
hears here and is thinking about founding a company, they
look somewhere, where is there
a scientist or a good
researcher or something that you
can put on your back as an applicant who you
can then work together  By the way, because
you are now coming to the
scientific background
and now we have already got over the biontech
greener you have
your list even higher I
don't have it on my list
I have my
brothers' jumps on it instead it wouldn't actually be
the right call, they are
not bwellers either, but they are much more
successful and have made
the success of Burning possible in the first place
through their financing, but we have
made a lot of money with Hexal, a generics manufacturer, I have been
there in the background for many years
famous stories that they even
financed a study vehicle,
otherwise,
from my point of view, please, the
most impressive German companies,
such identical twins,
and by the way, from Mülheim an der Ruhr,
I also like it very much, then I used to
move to Munich, but yes, I
also have a brother  or
twin saves that has far too little
attention in public
for the fact that you are still alive for
the values ​​that have created now
under and I was surprised that you
two just don't have it but
instead the different only the
words I thought about I found  for
the reasons that you say so therefore
quotation marks only a generics
company first built up so that
then already patented drugs
as soon as the patent expires then
produces cheaply but what you definitely
get is that afterwards you just
made high-risk investments
so that's it too  Entrepreneurship
I would never say not only in Wester
but also blatantly in banks so
really exactly
and have already started many things
from that is actually so
the next place for you are the
SAP founders no so you have third place yes
I have  it is in 4th place and
is actually just as ne to be
able to come up with SAP but then in the
end of course it did
n’t work out with the vaccine now in the pandemic,
but still taking this risk
and investing in an area
that is really future-oriented um
found  I with him or do I find him
totally impressive just like with
the ströms I actually
still have the two backgrounds on 3
and the hours as not in my top
ten because I just what I mentioned at the beginning
so this consideration what
is what  Innovation and this
innovation simply meant that
in a pandemic that
somehow led to the most massive
restrictions on freedom and
other things worldwide, we simply had the leverage to
fight it again and
I found that as an
entrepreneurial achievement from
Germany so impressive  that
I put them in third place for me in the
end
yes, but I think the stringmanns
deserve the mention because
what is also relatively typical when
you build really big tech companies is
that they just or say
scientifically based companies
that are supposed to be uncanny  So Cup Access
really has to invest,
so it's investment costs, so
whether you want to build a semiconductor plant
or a factory,
biontech still needs
the help of fibers to
commercialize it, so to speak, you also need
entrepreneurs like the crowds you can see
who then finance what we
said or what you also said with a view
to the DAX no, there is an incredible
amount of old money in Germany and
this money actually has to be used even more
to
bring the young companies into existence no  so
that people like ubershagen or something like that
then also get the money to
push such technologies forward
so we're now around I'm trying to
keep the book now
we've moved up from 4th place at pipp
that Bernd the founders had in 3rd place
you just talked a bit
about SAP and and since he
now represents Haupt and Platten but
there are more I would say the only
relevant German tech group so
the only one over 100 billion for
sure so are about ERP software so
um electronic resort man  could still have been
relevant from a German
tech group that is
relevant is also shopify on it
although now the channel is
sitting by a buddy exactly
we all saved ourselves yes actually
you could have done yes I
actually have at so it’s the end
of course also a bit unfair because
Plattner and Haupt of course
also had a longer life to show for
themselves by doing certain things
now maybe others in their
early 30s late 30s early 40s
haven’t done yet but I just find it
incredibly impressive what they do to
society, so to speak  In the end, you gave
back through
entrepreneurial
things, but you have Plattner,
you have Plattner Institute, it started its life,
that allowed a lot of
essential research and they were also incredibly involved in the
region,
well, apart from TSG
Hoffenheim, really  made an incredible amount of
social commitment no uh did
you have a plastner platteninstitut there is a
Potsdam science promotion further
fine then we come to place 2
my second place is uh Carl Zeiss from
Jena who is the founder of the
optical industry in Germany
you can say I think so has  the first
microscope built up to space
telescopes then at some point and it is
still relevant, among other things, there
are Carl Zeiss lines in the
SML machines that vaporize the chips,
so they are now super important
for the big tip producers, as in
turn there are readers from the Trumpf family
or  the company Trumpf AG inside the
Leibinger family unfortunately didn't
make it into the list either, but I find it
impressive is also managed by the woman
twice, even represented on
our
45 billion heavy, I think
Trumpf too and then actually build important
parts for microscopic
production  high-precision reader
[music]
but Carl Zeiss Finn is a brand
so sympathy for a compatriot from the
east probably yes and uh where that
speaks to sympathy so also
Shotglas AG so wine glasses all sorts of
things probably in the end
also Zeiss there is a second one  in
Saarland somehow if a lot of
glasses were still made but the Stadt AG
also emerged from Carl Zeiss, among other things, there
is also a
co-founder who I now have in fine Arno
but
seriously but precisely
[laughter]
in my top ten and maybe it
is  very interesting because we
really all agreed on number 1,
funnily enough, but before we
reveal that, so to speak, maybe take a
quick look who placed someone differently,
uh, you find
yourself, for example, we do
n't even have we have on the list is not a
trading company  For example, no,
I thought about it for a really long time, but
I wanted to, I think it's difficult,
because they're really innovative, you can
say that the discounters were
invented in Germany, and that made
sure that we have the lowest prices
and the worst, the bad
food, but
if  I would do a trade under the
or I would then act on the
but operate the group of
department stores so um but
Rudolf Karstadt by the way um is
an Essen group but the first store
in Wismar in Mecklenburg-Western Pomerania was
the first Karstadt department store that he
Georg  Wertheim the first Wertheim was
in Stralsund, 30 km from my
hometown
they are the first department stores
were set up in New York, i.e. in England and
America, but the people who have now
more or less adopted
Hermann Tiziani in Gera, by the way,
strangely enough, were really all
Ostendorf KaDeWe Georg Wertheim  and
Rudolf Karstadt, which is also
expanding incredibly quickly with it, they all
built 20 or 30 branches in the first 20 years,
so I would have liked to take one of them
because it’s difficult to single out one and
then take all 14, they didn’t make it for me,
but they have a
person like that  uhm i would say
stop
this retail criticism that is now
getting through to Peter for a moment i understand a large
part of it but yes both one person will help
your list where i say that it is
not actually possible so dieter schwarz
from the black group has to  you
have it there I just want to
say very briefly he currently has
429,000 employees are how many people
work there are somehow
almost 50 billion is one of the largest
companies in the world in terms of sales um the
guy owns it more or less
alone so that is of course number
1 on the list of the richest Germans uh
not to include him now uh he
built it up in his lifetime so he has to
be on it there you both
made mistakes yes I didn’t take that I
actually didn’t take it I have the
old one  So Karl and Theo Albrecht um
I would normally also be
in Germany um that's where they all come from um but
I actually so I
hesitated no so there are both
dealers there are an awful lot so
from the source catalog of course let's take it
kind of knows  about Otto
but incredibly great exciting you
somehow recently had Thorsten Teller as a
guest in your podcast
Fressnapf
and I decided in the end for the Aldi
brothers and against Dieter
schwarz because he black handed over
the business to Klaus Gerich as
manager relatively early  and I just
found that all the brothers
had operational responsibility for much longer over the years and
in the end that was what made the difference for me, so to speak
what Heilbronn
underlined probably
also benefited from him, no, and this
transformation that is
being initiated right now, everything is very
exciting, but as I said, in the end it
shows that they somehow
want to build a German AWS and so
there are really big ones  Plans that you I
think you
could
read about having your own disposal company built artificial people magazine
just like that Emerson style
and that's actually that's kind of the
German Amazon Lidl it's that but it
's what should happen with cars
what they have for cars
buy and resell
so one of the biggest players in the
field and really relevant customer
of the big car manufacturers so
in that respect you have to talk about it in any case
it will be up to me soon
for both of you is not on it you
at least have the um Aldi would there
on it absolutely I have it in 5th place
and you have Dieter black yes on four
no and yes but driven the principle that
I please listen first and then
afterwards I can switch my list a
bit back and forth depending on
how convincing it is now  explained
now I would say we want to
save place one again because
all three of us have it anyway, um, but we'll go in
first maybe into the
river place 10 we already know
exactly and then or better go through your list
from bottom to top  all
things, of course, for those who did
n’t have exactly so yes in the
bechtholz we already said ne is
also place 10 for me as for as for the
hip then Carl Zeiss has the on two
I have on 9 and I actually have a
total of three women in  on my list,
the greener ones that we
had already mentioned from Fresenius, but
in 8th place I have a Burda, namely
brother, the surname is
still known in the media world today and
I just found it incredibly
impressive that they ended up with the
World market leader in these
patterns, so
from a
really bad starting position,
actually, she was cheated on by her husband
and then she didn’t give in
any way or anything,
but at the time she just said
okay, look out, um, give me the publisher and
sort of settled down
to this world market leader really
developed with patterns and I found that
at that time also
a life's work yes that for me
then too and the small cell of
today's vacation so it has to be said
that's that that's from then
today's company where you  now that
Hubert has become and knows because he's
still alive erm sorry
exactly yes and at the top really 4
million copies worldwide
and of course the market is
relatively small compared to other markets but
on this market it
really is totally innovative
because you fought for your place and
I really thought that was very good
then you have he he she Kröner in 7th place
we were now in 8th place
Kröner and then place six always comes
directly the next question you almost
made a list of women only no but
yes  Exactly I'm actually
sixth I have Melissa Benz and the
surname is more familiar in the
automotive sector, first names are of course
TZexactly
for coffee filters and that's the
same thing I thought when I
researched it because I didn't think so either
It was so clear where that came from,
I was also totally impressed because
Melitta Benz, as a housewife,
always brewed this coffee for her husband
and in the past you obviously brewed this
coffee so that you
simply poured the hot water over it
and then just waited for
it  Whole coffee grounds somehow
settled or just tried to
pour out somehow, but somehow there were no
sieves that were um fine-pored enough, so
it always had this coffee powder in it
and then she somehow
took a piece of blotting paper from her son and
made it into the first coffee filter
and not only that I found that
alone I thought that was kind of
awesome, but she even
filed a patent, so she really had
her innovation protected
and um, I have to say today
Melitta, the group that will also be the
world market leader with sales of two billion  or or the largest
provider in the coffee system
are East Westphalia already companies
or a structure that you don't really
see where a woman is in the background
of the values ​​but
so
small but the story is of course convincing
and that's exactly totally so I found it
easy  really this innovation was
somehow already made in 1908, so more than
100 years old at the time when
women were really anything but
allowed to get involved at the forefront of the economy and so once, so
to speak, this idea of ​​innovation that
I found interesting, but the second was
still this idea of ​​sales  so
that she really went there and
said she takes it right away for ladies,
I'll say they have
coffee parties where they then in the end
present the coffee filter to others and this function of the coffee filter so in the end yes
exactly
and who invented it
okay so  we're going today also
invented it I think it's also from the military
exactly so
among other things and it's so the
brand you know you also own it's
okay so it was 6th place on your
5th place are my first ones is
exactly exactly had  I explained very quickly
why exactly in fourth place
I have the SAP founders so
nothing new now he also
spoke to me then Bayern Tag um Eslam
door and Urstein in third place and um
second place so now again stayed local in the
East, so to speak  and
of course I'm the NRW defender then I
voted Franz Haniel second
because I also found that to be an achievement again,
this really initiated industrialization in the end,
so we've set a timeframe
now that we
want to talk about and it became possible  this
industrialization only because of him because
back then he really, so to speak,
broke through this layer of rock, so to speak, as
the first
through which one could actually mine this deeper-
lying coal and before that
one had to remove this coal from above, so to
speak, which was far on the surface
and  and that's how
you could mine the coal really deep in the layers in the Ruhr area for the first time
and
all this germination time is the Ruhr area
just came about because of this innovation from
him or that was the innovation, so to speak, so
in the end you want the cheap energy to be
available  these people like
Krupp or something like that could run their entire stoneworks
that was just possible in the end
exactly that is and um platform and it
is very nice well I mean who do I tell
that is actually the Zollverein
and um is it Daniel
or  Trade traced back and
yes, for me that's actually
number 2
because he's just now that's a
bit apart Podcast because they had
taken up with the
Philipp Prize from KKR where we also
talked about entrepreneurship and he
introduced a new category
He had talked about these multi-geniuses
that he said there are
entrepreneurs who are so good and so
smart that they shouldn't just
run a company and erm
that was also a thing with Franz Handel,
so he really had something
besides this one  In the whole
history of coal, he also
somehow built up a hand like that, a
trading company,
steamships sold steam engines,
locomotives and so on, and um, and yes,
still in the Ruhr area today, one of the
very old, long-established families who
still invest with their holding company,
um, I thought  excited
invented the vertical integration if he
said the coal flakes together
okay
then we don't take first place there either
um but then I would
switch over on my list so my
10th place is actually a 10th place that the
pipette definitely has to bring
I think it's a surprise, but I
find Heinrich Schliemann's vita
so unbelievable and somehow
so inspiring that I
wanted to include him in it, so Heinrich Schliemann
is the Heinrich Schliemann you
might know because he
discovered archeology in Troy, but the means for it are
the  that I just procured and I
would say if I
can understand that correctly it was the one you
mask of that time and the
time at that time is still just
in the area of ​​what we defined
he was born in 1822 just in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommes  new Buko and
died in Naples in 1890 and in between there is
an unbelievably dazzling life
yeah um wanted to split up several times
then somehow didn’t get any further had
setbacks but the
corresponding sailing ships then
also got stranded with texts so only got as far as
Holland and then somehow
more started again  to
work my way up and then apparently
decided I'm going to Russia and
then I'm going to trade in
colonial goods there, so they say, but
in the end it's dyes, luxury
food industry, raw materials
that he was dealing with and
somehow built up his first fortune with it,
by the way, also learned a lot of different
foreign languages  totally impress
how much language he could somehow
uh Dutch probably from
his time at Texel and there were
Amsterdam spanish italian
portuguese russian uh English on
his stomach because when he was in Russia he
got that a brother
became a gold prospector in California
and that’s where Schliemann came from  also
to California his brother afterwards
he really did that because I
know when he sold the shovels to the gold prospectors
he had founded a bank
Instagram mento there where
the gold rush happened he
made so much money from the gold prospectors that he was there next to the
I can no longer
understand how many billions it
was, but it must
have been a portion that allowed everything possible,
among other things, then
after that it even came up with the idea of
saying I would become an archaeologist and
invent  completely new to me so
the thing about archeology when
I read it feels a bit like
today Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos
want to fly into space um back then
somehow archeology and I
invent ancient Greece had to have
the wrong one  Digged places because there were
certainly
numerous prohibitions simply
skipped there because I should have been allowed to dig,
but I find his life so
rich after all and if you
also think about what the world was like at that time,
you didn’t even fly from
Russia to the USA  it was just long
ship trips and then there in
another culture to build something up again,
so to speak, only to become again after
he had already started running in Russia
then that partly went on trips
showing his finds and then of course
went to Germany too  had several marriages
but if you have the natural so
if you read it like that and if you
look at it like that
of course including the legacy that
is of course the excavation treasures
then I think that is
someone who has to be on the list
yes he is simple  from the intellect
from the output of inheritance from the
lever probably also 500
commercial skillful
on it I have
not read a multi-value or several 100-
page biography and I am
always busy with
Wikipedia but read something again and
then there was an exhibition and stuff like that  but
I think I have an absolutely fascinating
personality and
with my plea I
can probably start in place
but he's actually with
me for the first time I put him in
tenth place
then we can make it short in
9th place because I couldn't  make the right
decision I actually wanted to celebrate
my original home a bit here too
that so many companies
were formed that has already been
mentioned again at various points in
Essen comes from you could have taken groups now
that you just talked me out of it a
bit you
could have taken Deichmann too  there is also a shoe
wholesaler there is a great documentary about it, hopefully
soon in the
podcast, one day
Karstadt could certainly have taken it, although
of course they didn’t end up being so
successful, but above all you
could have taken all of them eat everything
according to families, that was crazy  since that's
how it came out, um Deichmann, in the
end in terms of sales, I was quite
surprised, similar to someone who
can also take through the expensive
lawyer Chrissy Podcast, both
companies around between 4 and 5
billion in sales, only that
Thorsten in ours, so to speak,
built it himself  the 33 years and the
deichmanns for a much longer time
so you could have taken that too I
couldn't decide if I'm honest now
and while you did
a really impressive research
I tried again
to build an event so please forgive
me for that  I don't
want to commit myself to eighth place, anyway,
then I
naturally respected the truth for me,
um, they had to be seventh,
and maybe I got caught
on the wrong foot, I ca
n't do that  to say exactly but there
is for me in the pure moon
that is of course my own
story I started more than once
as an assistant to the board of directors
or the then boss of gut
and yes he had already
experienced this culture from the inside and of course it
a moon was also you said and
prisoner of war accordingly
also fought in the war for Germany
the wrong side
I don't know the details because I don't have to
say but what you see as a legacy in the end
is a company
that would also be in the DAX um there you are  and
above all management principles
that are quite impressive, so he
created this entrepreneurship in the company, so that there really are a
lot of people working decentrally, that
the company after him, um
Mark Wester and other very, very big ones,
has continued to grow,
so many many
Thomas Müller  Episode of
course more than one
has progressed in the end there was only alive
he had in bed when positioned in such a way
that Thomas Müller also tried
to create a German player that
could keep up with Google and Amazon,
they obviously wanted Amazon at the time
Buying shares and they somehow wanted to be part of ten at the time,
Thomas Müller said, so that was all
there was then no longer able to
control it myself,
but as I said, this principle, what
is it called intrapreneurships and, above
all, he also has it  who really
built many companies in one he has
somehow um meanwhile built the largest
book publishing company in the USA random house has
expectation has this book club on which
I built the whole thing as a man company
exactly
fused the New York Times
owned the New York Times 1994 um we obviously did
on  Mirroring a wide variety of other
publications, you can say
they also monopolies what entrepreneurial
performance
you could now start
discussing what Springer actually is,
but from a media point of view, that’s where I come
from, then I notice that my
passion has to be on the list there again
uhm totally impressed by what he built
and that is also very big
families did not quite but
mostly made great deals in the end
yes I would have
asked 30 years ago who from Germany can keep
up with Google and come on then I would have
that  maybe
all the experiments with Napster and so it
didn't happen like that
I'm curious now he's coming
namely the third generation so there
was that of from from will and then
I'll come his grandchildren in
soon um let's see how
I hope that they will come to the podcast,
namely in conversation, so that on the
side then in sixth place Greens have
already talked about it just as
impressively in fifth place I have
a completely different person, namely
Bertha Benz and now really Benz with
NZ  not with
TZ um that's Karl Benz's wife
and in the end you can say she's that
in neblerin
the
automotive location Germany is totally
funny we've been talking here for almost an
hour or a little over an hour
and the automobile was in the
public debate and  in terms of
economic power or so much does not matter
to us
in any form and if then with
a female entrepreneur and not
with Ferdinand Porsche or Carl Benz
or
God for Daimler so it's funny
you can ask the question which of
the three big car companies
we have  because now forgotten or how come
Porsche is strictly speaking Austrian
so then you have to say uh quant was
already mentioned indirectly at least
once as BMW Urquell and
uh now with the whole Daimler Benz
saga I have now consciously
called a woman but a story  to be able to
tell that maybe some did
n't have that in mind decided for the woman
from von carl-benz because
the company wasn't doing well when
you thought nothing would be said
okay I'll take care of myself then
made trips and all that
proved that the cars
they invented
could really drive with the engine and did
test drives then there's
a story somehow that the first
pharmacy in the world
was the first gas station in the world because they
filled up on these trips
100  km no and then I also had
to prepare for it, it's totally funny that
she had several breakdowns on the way where
she somehow cleaned the fuel hose with the hat pin
and somehow
repaired the ignition with the garter
and so really
multi-talented and actually too
wait for the financier you have to say
ne more or less earlier than she did because she
financed her husband while he did the
technical
universities the questions yes well here
it’s honestly not quite like that but uhm
well you have to name because you
also wrongly don’t have it
in that respect I have to  Of course,
add something later, er,
Bertha Benz is also a great story,
so
in the end it’s enough to
just read through Wikipedia and you
’re totally inspired, so even if
it’s only what the podcast
can achieve that you remember Heinrich
Schliemann or rennen again  or
look and we are always looking for
women too if the next conference by
Lea and so much and Verena would
then somehow be called Kröner but
then I don't know Bertha Benz so it's
exciting that something like that exists and
of course everything was different for a woman at the time
just then we have
already talked about Dieter Schwarz Lidl in fourth place in
third place
I also have Hopp und Plattner and
in second place you forced me a
bit into the situation
that we are now local heroes from
our
places after we  come present repeat again
very briefly with the tip
what then the kaiz means for you what the
Franz Haniel I have revealed my Essen
local colorist already in 9th place just
below but I've been
in Hamburg and here for somehow more than 20 years now
is not yet a hamburger
on the list and that can't be, especially
since I recently did the podcast
because people or dad
and uh Klaus Peter bold um
right
we also
do about you
and he also has a brown
past, I think the family
at least  but of course also multi
genius with with bold nail of the forwarding company
with dad and also
something like that of course also means gigantic no matter so
we don’t have bold ones on the
list would be cool to have the one on the podcast
I certainly think it’s
up there so one of the few  There
are many minutes alive they would
obviously die and yes the list of the
living is not that long he would
definitely be one um and the gentleman
is black I think my list is the
other one who is still alive um also just ca
n't be made public
and my hope is very strong on the
rivers alright but in
second place
I have Albert Berlin and um here in
Hamburg they know the ball in Dammstraße
named after him the two cities
but his area in Hamburg on
a south of the Elbe where so
such large
jackets or homes were built for emigrants
someone who was definitely very
strongly socially committed because he also
came from a small background then had
a bit of the disadvantage that
he was never a big businessman himself when
he was in Hamburg society at the time  also founded various things,
also founded his own shipping company,
which would later be
taken over by Hapag and yes, he was then
written down at Hapag to be the boss there, but
that wasn't his company,
it belonged to various
families or different bikes
and entrepreneurs since today
listed on the stock exchanges and also belongs in parts to
a bold but at that time the
Hapag Hamburg America package has come
to an end
invented today, in fact, um, because ships
let the Mediterranean Sea sail and then there
were people who came along has also
always come up with such cool things,
made it between 6 that there were
people who somehow these right
emigrants that was the business, no, that
he was in the business of people
in the USA, so to speak,
I think a father's business was the
same that he just
put people in place, so to speak,
in fact it's probably
somehow close to what is
criticized today that they also
rightly saw differently  because the people
in some parts of the USA can live much better
he did it and he did it in a
very social way after
he made it a huge patriot I
think he was sympathetic to Hamburg
for Germany was a Jew and um he was
very strongly opposed to him  First
World War and it's that it's being
canceled that it doesn't
take place, uh, so if you look at the
entire preparation again, it's exciting to
see how individual entrepreneurs who
really do have international contacts all over the world at the end of the
business they're running
and then really then there was also
a very close relationship with the Kaiser, the
German Kaiser at that time and we
really tried to
initiate peace negotiations somehow and so
in the background that
is perhaps one of those roles that
the public is sometimes not even
aware of  is that
entrepreneurs also
have an influence on me in the end, which
you sometimes don't even notice, even
if he failed in the end with
his efforts, but I found that
interesting, so as
a Hamburg patriot you have to have
albert Ballin with double  -in for,
however, listening south of the Elbe,
which I asked myself, as I
said, incredibly impressive
story when I
looked at everything in the preparation,
but as you already said,
a quotation mark only at the end, only an
employee manager, this,
this position  is general director
um is of course in the end he
made a huge difference because the
share price is somehow from or
the company climbs from 15 to 180 million
at the time only with the
logic you would have to say someone
like now out and back in  your home
to jump your actual home
berthold-beitz also an incredibly
influential person for a company
but also only
two generations ago
so the dynasty
somehow goes back to the 19th century and
you can only do both now, so to speak, then
somehow after the second
World War around or around 60 years ago
I think so that's my
question the best managers do ne that
could
be at Lidl who helped
build it up at Lidl, so there's also
Bert's as the question of which manager
manager there was apart from
Mohn because he deliberately managed so decentrally
and not at all because this
principle that I decide now
autocratizes everything here,
which was also revolutionary, so a
bit that is also to
involve people and um, um, to issue shares to employees and stuff like that, that, that, that
alright but in the end we are left with the
question who is number 1 we all
three have the same person erm exactly why
you have number 1 yes Werner
von Siemens is actually on one thing
I think he built a huge brand definitely
many  Companies that
ultimately
spin out companies like this because Siemens once again
created many listed companies that originally came from Germany,
you can probably say it
was electrified and then the telephone network
telegraph network was built there are
probably still there, so if you still
have a landline telephone then it’s in
Usually built by Siemens, I would say
have a medical technology division, have
built electric turbines, a
power plant division, for which, together
with Robert Bosch, maybe the
electrical contractor in Germany, and has
therefore simply contributed a lot to industrialization,
just like in Berlin,
also with its own district as
Siemensstadt in the direction of Spandau
yes I think then very emplematic
entrepreneur for Germany has
this technical aspect inventor is
aspect
yes for me there was actually one
simply whose invention simply
changed an awful lot the
electric tram
then of course that the telegraphed
cables the yes then yes  also partially
between India and the European
continent so that has
simply accelerated the world now in terms of
tram transport
mobility simply accelerated the
telegraph lines have uh
simply renovated communication radically
and of course I think it’s an
amazing lifetime achievement
yes so I can’t anymore
I find that much to add um if you
also look at how many DAX companies
emerged from Siemens with all the
um I'm Office has given which
role Siemens bosses have also been there for many
years yes okay then podcast
I hope to have a small field soon
So yeah, in the evening it's almost
a bit like Chancellor in
Germany, not quite like that, but
you really have an impact there and um, he just
built it up
because that's the one thing for all of us,
you have to say it's crass for you too  So
most of the names that Church GPT somehow
spat out actually
appeared in some form on our lists, no, they
somehow have Karl-Friedrich bands you that
then Bertha Benz only Adolf Dassler,
funnily enough, none of us but
I believe it  because of the brown
past ne
that would be Reinhard Mond maybe
also
what did he write who invented the cleats ne definitely
one of the biggest
sporting goods manufacturer
so I mean bigger so in
a top 30 I would definitely
see him definitely  In the top 10
I wouldn't have it in it now, but
of course it's a blatant life's work, but
adidas was overtaken by Nike in the end,
so
we have to let it take the butter off the
bread that's also
amazing, I still find it in this segment  there
is now somehow a lot of space
for all these doodle lemons
and once and and on the poor thing is
that you somehow can't
get it tight in the end so that shows for me
why he's not on my
list ne it's just like he has
nothing was invented or no innovation
was produced that is so irreplaceable
that you can't get past this company, so to speak, well
that's in the end it's a product of course
okay now cleated shoes and
then maybe improved something in the
sneaker area at that
moment  where he then sold the
wider masses, so to speak, about the miracle of Bern
as an innovation,
but in the end if I can no longer do anything
modern then the technological
one can then somehow
switch to the competitor, no, um, not
such a big fashion, one would say yes  exactly
then he has one of them then somehow
footed them and then if he does
n't somehow fall behind with the
next
yes gimmick somehow technological
gimmick maybe what the school
can do even better then such a brand
is quickly gone again what are we
still learning  from our lists from
our research so the quota for women
is I would say almost better than
I feared we all had
at least two at best four or
five women even on the list
I think I overlooked a pair of glasses bands
then those so that’s a great
quota  almost surprisingly good uhm something
else you liked
yes that’s the case with me for example well
I have now except for else greener you have to
say unfortunately no
woman has managed
to build up a real global company on her own so
we have significantly more men that
is  I think something like that, yes, if you want such
a perspective, you
naturally wish for something like that, that there are just these
founding stories that are
purely female, um, and um, otherwise,
yes, Pippi said at the beginning that
's a lot of old history,
just where we really come a long way  have
to look back to somehow see the
great innovations from Germany
if you now exclude Bavaria Tag
also sAP is
somehow already a few decades old ne that
is of course a bit of a pity that
you have such a top ten without yes yes
that one  the best in the end in the
USA well we just
mentioned and
we deliberately left out a lot of the trade
no well you can
certainly break your voice about the three big chemists well then
we have it
now I think a bit
distorted in that we then the the
not much space if
you would have measured it now, e.g. after
wealth we would of course
trade a lot more maybe
a car beißheim Metro would be
very difficult
very complicated
exactly
how good trading is in the end suitable for
getting rich so jeff is a
Example of today's world but we
will be from Karstadt then
from Rossmann Podcast if you
could tell Torsten Teller himself afterwards
that he is surprised how good it
is for retail and and
you can also do it
Founder is even missing, yes
Werner exactly
yes, one could actually have considered
whether one missed Heinz Nixdorf and Konrad
Zuse
for the first computers
for a long time with the technological upheaval in the personal
computer market  I
thought about it because I also think what
you see with many of these
people we have on the list
is um the importance of individual
entrepreneurs and individual companies
for cities, so Germany is
incredibly decentralized when it
comes to these billions of companies, so that's
how it is now  a um Dieter Schwarz in
Heilbronn or
Reinhard Mohn in Gütersloh no, so there
are an incredible number of cities that have such an
amazing company and then, of
course, the next thing on top of it, if you
go to Paderborn afterwards, were also incredibly
prank, no, and yes,
all of Stuttgart is somehow Daimler
okay,
we  spoke Essen
[music]
you just really see
how broad our economy is in the end
and you can see
unfortunately but also I find relatively little
yes computer technology or very old
computer technologies so Heinz nothing
on it Zuse and also Platter and Top with
SAP, these big
digital companies are missing, uh, the last one,
amazing, actually, what the
whole
financial departments are not in there, so
Insurance Banking USA looks who are
the rich guys of today or
so in the last few decades, these are the
people, so core finance  Then there are
some people who sell the financial fleet
or something else, um, they
are the players on our
Carl von Thieme, who was um, um,
born in 1844 and one of the founders of
Munich Reber, so he’s the largest
reinsurer in the world and
at the same time I wasn’t even
aware of that  Allianz also had when
life called, well, two,
two such mega corporations, both of course
now in Munich and
both of them somehow go back to him,
um, of course, the 11th place for you sounds yes,
but in the end I decided against it
because  he was just
founded and then somehow
managed as general director for a long time,
but that was a case where I
said the majority of the
company would be growth is
just after him, no,
that was already a big
reinsurer back then, but  if you
look at what it means today, it was
more likely to have been done
by employee managers in the last few decades
and that's why I did
n't take it into account in the end, there
are always people here who
we think will be there in a few years
or a few  Decades that
could be on the list
are there any Germans
on the road and they say okay that could
be really big then
Christian Hacker will soon be on it with Republic
in 10 or 20 years or are there the
founders of the question in the end is whether we
at some point say that Bayern are tag
or even higher up because they are
developing drugs that
can really cure cancer or something like that,
well I think that would of course be
the next step where you
say so now okay no so vaccine in
the  Pandemic is one thing, but if you
really change the world in such a simple way
that you really
somehow stop illnesses like cancer and also
get sick, maybe then somehow
in the end you can somehow solve them with an injection or whatever,
that would of course be something like that
and otherwise
Celona SAP will also have three stompers and
then again all three computer
scientists
Podcast delicious he also
raved about celones so
the German company already had them they are
already worth 10 billion so yes yes yes
yes
of small texts that's there  then at
some point Marvel Fusion did one
recently in the podcast, no, that's where there are
such real innovations
that can somehow help
to prevent or mitigate the climate crisis
or whatever, so of
course that could be a segment
where groundbreaking innovations
might be possible  okay, so it was fun for me to
write down all these 200 years and to look for
who are the most important the most
exciting most inspiring German
entrepreneurs and
of course we have
probably forgotten something despite all the
crowd support and chat GPT support and
our own research and
somehow we didn't  everything done right
and people definitely see things differently
is also perfectly clear, but
at the end we want
to share the idea somehow that
people who can vote how is the
final list, we would
consolidate our three lists and
then do something  we Flo exactly, so
if in the end we deliberately
decided against presenting a uniform list,
that means we would now
simply find information about it in the show notes
and then give
you the
opportunity to vote again on LinkedIn or your
top ten  So just create it to
follow him on LinkedIn
and I'll go to my
account
it will be and if necessary you can
vote on like and say who you think is
best now and share
our Werner von Siemens
assessment with everyone on LinkedIn or do you think more like
me it couldn't
be worse
in the sense of many many  Thank you yes thank
you until next time Ciao all right